probably read one to two hours a day
uh which and that puts me in the top
.0001
i think that alone accounts for any
material success that i've had in my
life and the intelligence that i might
have
[Music]
you've said before you think of books as
throwaways how did you come to think
about books like that and what impact
has that had on what you read
i mean that's really an impact of the
internet
once the internet came along i think
it's destroyed everybody's attention
span because now all of humanity's works
are available to you at any given time
and you're being interrupted
constantly so
just our attention span goes down our
bit of focus goes down but at the same
time we just become
more judicious we also want uh we want
the meat
and the
the problem with books is that to write
a book to publish it publish a physical
dead tree uh book it just takes a lot of
work and effort and money so sometimes
people
start putting
long uh wrapping long books around
simple ideas those are probably my least
favorite books it's kind of why i avoid
the whole business and self-help
category because you you generally have
one good idea and it's buried in uh
hundreds or thousands of pages and lots
of anecdotes um so what happened was i
just noticed that sometime in the late
90s i stopped reading as much as i used
to and i started reading more blogs i
started reading less books and more
blogs and great blogs like farnham
street
uh you know uh kevin simler's blog
melting asphalt and so on you get
incredibly smart people digestifying
simplifying uh and and writing these
great things but it's only a page or two
or three pages so i got really into
blogs uh but then i'd stop reading books
and a lot of the oldest wisdom is
actually in books uh and with books
you're now talking about the combined
works of all of humanity as opposed to
just who happens to be blogging right
now so i realized i missed that
and then with the kindle and the ibooks
coming along that allowed me to start
treating books like i treat blogs which
is
when i go to a blog i'll actually skim
through lots of articles until i find
one that looks really interesting i'll
read that whole article all the way
through and maybe take notes so now i
treat books the same way which is i'll
skim through a large number of books
i'll put them down i'll jump around back
forward middle
until i find a part that's interesting
then i'll just consume that piece and i
won't feel guilty about having to finish
the entire book uh because i just view
it as a blog archive right it's like a
like a blog might have 300 posts on it
and you could read just the two three
five that you need right now and i think
you can think of a book the same way and
then that opens the world and web of
books back open to us
instead of it being uh buried somewhere
uh i think you know like many people i
know of a lot of friends uh who are
currently stuck on a book somewhere
and if you ask people if they read
everybody says they read everybody says
they're reading a book they can answer
which book they're reading but the
reality is
very few people actually read and
actually finish books yeah and i think
yeah and i think that's probably because
of all these societal and personal
um
rules that we've put up like you must
finish a book and you must read books
that are good for you and you can't read
junk food books and this is a hot book
right now and so on the reality is i
don't actually read that much compared
to what people think like the re i
probably read one to two hours a day
uh which and that puts me in the top
.0001
i think that alone accounts for any
material success that i've had in my
life and the intelligence that i might
have because
real people don't read an hour a day
real people i think read a minute a day
or less
uh so
making it an actual habit is the most
important thing and how you make it a
habit doesn't matter it's very much like
exercise or working out do something
every day it almost doesn't matter what
you do so the people who are obsessing
over like should i be weight training or
should i be doing tennis or should i be
doing pilates or should i be doing the
high intensity training method versus
the happy body which is whatever they're
missing the point the important thing is
to do something every day it doesn't
matter what it is so the same way i
would argue the important thing is to
read every day and it's not and it
doesn't matter it almost doesn't matter
what you read because eventually you'll
read enough things and your interest
will lead you there that that will
dramatically improve your life so just
like the best workout for you is the one
that you're excited enough to do every
day the same way i would say the best
books to read or the ones that are books
or blogs or twitter or whatever anything
with ideas and information and learning
the best ones to read are the ones that
you're excited about reading all the
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you